foreign
blogging why should you start blogging
and how do you start a blog from the
very scratch but before that I am Mark
campman I'm going to be your digital
navigator for this video and if you
would like to subscribe to our YouTube
channel don't forget to click the
Subscribe button below
so let's get started blogging for
beginners let me give you a few facts
and figures about blogs before we dive
into the topic did you know that there
are more than 600 million blogs on the
internet and every day over 2 million
blog posts are published on all those
blog posts that are out there 77 of
Internet users they read blog and they
leave about
77 million comments per month on all
these blog posts so it is a massive
um place where you can get engagement
and where you can get people talking
about the things that you're writing
about now people that include visuals to
their blogs they will see that they get
about 94 percent more views than those
people that do not add visuals to their
blog surprisingly Tumblr is the the most
used blogging platform with over half a
billion blogs out there but there are 60
million blocks that are powered by
WordPress also did you know that blocks
are the second most form of media used
in content marketing so lots about
blogging lots of facts they're out there
they're key they're relevant and this
blog is going to introduce you to how to
get started with a Blog now blogs have
been around for a very long time yeah do
you know what the name of the first
block was and who created it was it A B
C or D well let me give you the answer
Justin Hall started links.net in 1994 as
a student at a at a college becoming one
of the first widely read blowers out
there in the late 1990s the first blocks
were created primarily serving as
personal journals for small groups of
friends or for family now in the early
2000s blogging tools and services became
more widely available and it is also
when I got my first experience in
blogging when my son went on a on a gap
year traveling in in Southeast Asia and
he shared his photos through the
internet on a on a Blog so he found
internet cafes during his journey and in
each Cafe he started up his blog and
added a photo so that's how I could
follow his his trip so it makes it
became easier and easier for people to
start to create and maintain their own
blogs in 2002 the term blog was coined
and became widely used to describe a
website that serves as an online journal
or a diary so in 2004 the political
world started to get an idea about a
power of blogs they emerged and played a
role in shaping public opinion
influencing selections 2005 to 2010 was
the big growth of blocks and they
started to gain popularity and they came
into sort of the um into the more widely
discussable areas like photography blogs
and recipe blogs and then in the 2010s
businesses got to see the power of blogs
and they started to use blocks as a
mainstream form of communication and for
other people as self-expression with
millions of blogs covering every
possible subject and serving a diverse
range of audiences so today blogging
continues to play a significant role in
the rise of social media and it has a
very big impact on the way people
communicate and consume information
online a fantastic tool to learn to find
out about what's happening in the world
was fine to find out what's happening in
particular niches that you're interested
in and a great way to start sharing your
your own opinion so what will we be
talking about we're going to be talking
about what is a Blog what skills do you
need for blogging why actually should
you create a blog what are the types of
blog posts that you can create and I'm
going to show you some examples of those
different types of blog posts how do you
create a blog and I'm going to give you
some block writing tips to close off
with the that on the video today so
let's get into it what is a Blog
now there are many different definitions
of a block yeah their blog can be a
personal blog it can be a corporate blog
it can be a news blog yeah so a personal
blog is where it's a type of Vlog where
individuals share their thoughts their
opinions their experiences their um
their stories on a particular topic or a
particular range yeah these type of
blogs are very easy to set up and they
don't cost a lot of money but it's very
much with a personal Focus
businesses they usually have corporate
blogs it's a type of block by creating
this by a company and it can be used for
marketing it can be used for Branding it
can be used for communication purposes
for lead generation usually they share
company news they share productive
updates or industry insights yep so it's
also really good to engage with
customers and to get in a dialogue with
customers to build relationships and to
create
um thought expertise in a particular
niche the third type of blog that you
can see in this definition of a blog is
a news blog it's a type of blog that
focuses on reporting and analyzing
current events current news stories
what's happening in the world from a
particular angle it could be one
journalist it could be a group of
journalists it could be a media
organization yeah and it can cover a
wide range of topics or it can focus on
a particular Niche like entertainment or
like technology so it can be used to
create different perspectives on new
stories or to supplement the traditional
new stories but if we're looking at the
plain definition of a block if you look
at all the blogs they work from the same
concept
yeah a blog is a type of website serving
as an online journal or diary and it
consists of posts on a particular topic
or a particular theme yeah now a Blog
can be created by an individual or by
businesses and let's say as I said
earlier they can serve different
purposes for personal or for business or
for news they're very easy to create
blogs and that makes them so powerful
then you can use Simple blogging
software there's lots of free tools
available and you can get started within
five minutes they have lots of features
like commenting yes so and by using the
commenting functions you can allow
engagement with your readers and you can
really build up a community
now you can find blogs on specific
Standalone websites like a Blog website
or you can find them on
um embedded within a corporate corporate
website you could even blog on social
media networks like LinkedIn or um or
Facebook
and they often use a Content management
system yep to to create a blog to manage
the blog and to add new content new
pages on your blog
blogging for me is the easiest way to
get started with social media yeah so
they played a significant role in the
growth of social media and it had
fundamentally changed the way businesses
communicated with them with their
customers yes so and and how people sort
of consume information
yes or blocks they have a number of
things in common
yeah so if you go to a Blog each block
you will see a number of recurring
things the first thing of course that
you see are the blog posts they are the
Articles or the entries written or
published on the blocks and they can be
in different presentation formats yeah
you can see it in little thumbnails you
can see it in the headlines
or you can see just a scroll down of all
the blog posts but the blog posts are
obviously the core of each blog post
blogs have comments you can switch off
the comments if you want but most blogs
they have commenting and they are an
important part of a Blog because they
allow you to engage with the author yeah
or that the author can engage with their
readers so that gives a platform for
discussion for feedback and for
interaction around to blog
yeah when you start blogging you may
have a you may build up a big library of
blogs of blog posts yeah so a common
feature on every blog is that they have
categories and tags yep and you see them
on the column on the right on blog posts
and that means that you can easily
access previous content
so you're not stuck to the main article
but you give people access to other
content through categories through tags
or the most popular posts or the last
five posts blogs also have an about page
what is this blog all about it provides
reader with information about the author
of The Blog yeah the purpose of the blog
the mission of the blog so some
background information good blogs also
have a search box
yeah it's another way where you can
easily search for Content yeah that has
already been published on the blog
now a Blog without sharing buttons yeah
is like you're keeping it a secret so
one of the powerful features of a Blog
is that you as the author can share it
on social media but you can also ask
your readers to share it on social media
by using the sharing buttons
then there is the archive section where
it organizes the post by month by year
or by category again making it easy to
access previous content
and then many blogs have a call to
action
yeah so that is a button that encourages
readers to take a specific action like
subscribing to the blog or downloading
an ebook or signing up for a newsletter
yeah so it's very good tool to start
creating and building your audience
and on top of that you need to think
about the design and the navigation of
your blog is very important and we
talked about that in our other blogging
video that we posted a few weeks ago yes
so those are the common elements of a
Blog
so let's dig a bit deeper we talked
about yeah how a Blog can be personal it
can be for business it can be news as
long as it is in a specific topic yes so
around that topic or theme you can start
sharing your thoughts sharing your ideas
your knowledge and you can express
yourself so most some of the most
important and in demand topics for blogs
are lifestyle yeah like topics like
Fashion Beauty Health Wellness travel
and food are very popular
they have a very wide appeal and that's
very personal relevance to readers as
well
technology is a very hot topic yeah
showed a vast change of technology and
Innovation technological developments
there's always something to write about
there's always news around technology
yes so that is a very hot topic another
topic is personal finance people love to
know more about how to manage their Pi
finances and blogs can be a really good
way to help the readers and giving them
tips in how to manage their Finance in a
range of topics from savings investing
debt management and budgeting yet
there's blogs about Business and
Entrepreneurship they are very popular
from starting a new business yeah to
growing an existing one how to relate to
your customers there's a huge demand for
top four blocks around the theme of
business and business support
now there's news websites there's news
blogs around current events that cover
the latest news yeah they are popular
they can focus on a particular area like
what's it like politics or technology or
they can cover a more broad range as
well
there's creative blogs creative writing
creative literature writing yes so blogs
that are about creative writing and
about literature they can be a great
source of inspiration
and then finally personal development is
a very big category in blogs a very
popular category you have personal
development and self-improvement like
personal growth self-care
self-improvement they're really popular
and they are relevant to people's
day-to-day life yeah so these are some
of the most popular blog posts and the
block topics that people
um that people are interested in so for
you start looking into the topics if you
want to start blogging yeah and see if
you can pick a sort of a a a topic that
is Within These Within These categories
so is blogging difficult do I need a
wide range of skills for blogging well
it's not too difficult but of course
people have lots of different questions
about blogging before they start how do
I start a blog how do I come up with
ideas for my blog content how do I get
traffic to my blog how often should I
publish on my blog post
how do I monetize my blog what should I
write about what should I include in my
blog post how do I write an exciting
headline how do I promote my blog on
social media how do I engage with my
readers how do I track the success of my
blog lots and lots of questions yeah and
of course to answer all these questions
you do need to have certain skills
before you start blogging so let's have
a look at those skills
so to be successful with a bloke and to
successfully start a blog there are some
skills that you need
of course you can work on those skills
you can start building up those skills
but these are the five topics that are
playing an important part of your
blogging work your blogging activity
there's writing
there's search engine optimization
there's marketing there's web design and
there's social media
yeah so first you need to be able to
write you need to research you need to
write in a clear concise and engaging
manner
yep and that is a skill in itself and of
course when you start blogging
you you may not have that much
experience but when you have been
blogging for six months to a year you
will see that it gets easier and easier
the next thing you need to do is to be
able to optimize your blog posts for
search for Google for Bing yeah so that
they those search engines will find your
blog posts when you publish them
yeah and a very important part of your
search engine optimization is to
identify the keywords that are relevant
for your business and are relevant for
your blog and then you need to
understand how to use those keywords
effectively
then of course you need to Market your
blog you need to grow an audience you
need to get people to subscribe to your
blog maybe to start building an email
list yes so you need to understand email
marketing you need to know online
marketing to promote your blog you need
to know how to do that you need to know
where to do that you may want to look at
affiliate marketing which means you can
promote other people's products on your
blog and you would get a a small
commission for that yes so lots of
marketing activities that you need to
look into to actually to publish your
blog and make it become visible and make
it become popular
now of course there is the web design
element for your blog as well and those
are skills that you need to have there
are very simple tools as you will see
later yeah that you can use to set up
your your blog there's free tools that
you can use there's more advanced tools
as well and as with many things with the
more advanced tools and the premium
tools that you use you get more quality
you get more options you get often a
better design yeah so that is the
balance that you need to strike between
hey how much do I want to do for free
and want to do simple compared to do you
want to invest some money and do you
want to have a more advanced website yes
so that is of the balance that you need
to do but you do need to have some basic
web design skills and then finally you
need to have your social media skills
yes social media is a key part of
promoting your blog on the Social Web
and you need to know how to do that you
need to know how to set it up how you
need to know how to create those social
media posts and how to track them when
they um when you have published them
yeah so lots of skills that you need but
it doesn't mean that you need to be an
expert immediately when you start with
that yeah but it is it is important that
you recognize those topics and that you
start building experience for that
okay so if you feel that you have those
skills
yeah then is that enough for you to
start creating a Blog yeah there's some
other questions that you need to ask
yourself first of all one of the biggest
questions you need to ask doesn't matter
yourself is what am I going to write
about
yeah do I have a passion for writing and
sharing my knowledge about a certain
topic do I have a passion about a theme
about a topic am I do I have a passion
about technology do I have a passion
about health yeah so you need to have
that passion because when you start
developing your blog and writing your
blog post it takes in a it takes time it
takes effort and the more passionate you
are about the topic that you write about
then that time in that effort doesn't
matter you don't feel like it's taking
all the time because you're doing
something that you really really like
you also need to have very clear goals
yeah what are you going to do with your
blog why are you having this blog you
also need to have the time and the
resources to regularly create new blog
posts
yeah because there's nothing more
frustrating and not nothing more
damaging on your website if you start a
blog but then after five posts you stop
with it
yeah there's so many websites where you
go to and then you go to the blog and
the last blog post was 24 months ago
yeah then it almost works against you
yeah it shows hey there's a Blog but
they haven't taken the efforts to
um to start a blog
yes so you need to have that passion you
need to have clear goals now businesses
they often have very clear goals for a
Blog yeah they want to use a Blog to
increase traffic to the website to drive
conversions yet to get people to the
website to get them to convert into a
prospect it helps them in contributing
to their social media efforts it's great
way to build client trust to be seen as
an expert in their field yep it gets a
great way for developing the brand and
reinforce the key messages around the
brand it's great to differentiate
yourself from your competitors and it is
a good way to encourage engagement with
your customers yeah so for businesses
there's almost like a no-brainer they
want to they they use blogs because they
can see that they get a lot of benefits
but for you let's take it very simple
yeah there are five reasons if you want
to start your blog there's five reasons
why you can why why you should create a
blog
yes first of all if you want to express
yourself creatively then blogging is the
best place to do this
yeah so if you haven't if you are
passionate about a topic and you want to
share that knowledge then blogging is
the number one place to go to yeah
second if you want to show yourself as
an expert or build yourself as an expert
and you want to grow want to grow an
audience around this you want to grow a
follower base who are interested in
learning about what you have to say
about your topic yeah so if you want to
establish expertise and build an
audience then you have to start using a
Blog for that
thirdly a reason why you must create a
blog if you want to build a community if
you want to network with other people if
you want to network with prospects get
them to your website get them to convert
yeah if you want that to grow your
business then blogging is certainly a
fantastic vehicle to help you achieve
that another reason to create a blog is
that you want to enhance your writing
and your thinking skills
yes so blogging is not writing a book
blogging is not writing an ebook because
and people may be scared of that it may
be too
um too much of a uh
um an unknown field but start writing
small simple articles on your blog
thereby you develop your writing and you
develop your thinking skills very good
reason for you to start blogging you
don't even have to publish it you can
just keep it your private blog yeah but
then when you feel comfortable you can
then start publishing it
and then finally and that's how I
started as well with my own business if
you want to start making money if you
want to start your own business
you have then a blog is a fantastic
vehicle to help position you in your
markets in your industry
yeah so it's a great vehicle that can
help you to become self-employed or make
more money so lots of reasons for you to
start creating a Blog yes so now that
we've seen what you need yeah for
creating and start blogging yeah why you
should start blogging uh let's have a
look at the different types of blog
posts that you can create on your blog
there are many different types of posts
and I'll give you a list of them in um
in a minute and each blog post each type
of blog post they serve a different
purpose and a different requirement from
the readers but there are some reasons
that
apply to every reader first of all your
blog post must provide value
yet different readers have different
preferences to the type of content they
like to read but value is the same for
everybody yeah so if you provide value
to your readers you keep them engaged
and very important you keep them coming
back another common characteristics for
book for all blog posts is that you need
to keep them fresh and you need to keep
them interesting
so it means you need to make sure that
the content is up to date but also that
you do a variety of post types because
that keeps it fresh that keeps it
interesting it also
sort of helps in breaking up the um the
monotone
um sort of style of a Blog yes so use
different content Styles use different
formats use different visuals to keep
your content alive and interesting
another common element for all blog
posts is you need to cater to the
different learning styles
some people may read want to read
text-based blog posts some people may
want to see more visual content or
infographics some people may want to see
video content yeah so over that Variety
in your blog posts so you can cater for
different type of audiences with
different type of learning styles and
then very important with a Blog and each
blog post sort of caters for that it
showcases your Authority
Yeah by offering different types of blog
posts you can demonstrate that you're
the expert regardless the type of blog
post that you do but people will come
back to your blog if they see you as
yeah this person knows what he's talking
about and that can help you build
credibility with the readers and
establish a yourself as a thought leader
in your industry yes so overall offering
a variety of different types of blog
posts can help you attract readers but
not only that you can retain your
readers and you may get them back they
may become part of your audience as long
as you showcase your expertise and keep
your content fresh and interesting
so given those common elements of blog
posts let's look at some different types
of blog posts the most popular blog
posts are list based posts yeah they
provide a list of tips of resources or
other information on a specific topic
people love lists people love the top
five things in this or 10 things you may
have missed yeah a really good example
of a list based post is life hacker live
hacker gives you life hacks yes so nine
food labels that don't mean what you
think they mean yeah 15 ways to build a
better breakfast sandwich mine of the
most dangerous driving and emergencies
little tips list of tips people love
those and the way they are presented on
this blog is actually quite interesting
yeah instead of having a long article
about this they actually have a short
introduction but they do them as
slideshows why not yeah it's visual
yeah so here is one yeah so here is the
next slide yeah so black eyes here you
see little highlight of what is uh what
what it's about yeah animals in the road
next one is a car with mattress flapping
on the rooftop may look funny but you
don't want to be behind it yes so lots
of good tips and people love these type
of blogs
the next one is thought leadership posts
so they express the author's thoughts or
feelings on a specific topic and
particularly for businesses these are
very important because by building
thought leadership
which means being seen as an expert in
your field you're also building trust
now one of the best thought leadership
blogs in the industry is Harvard
Business review
yeah so lots of articles on a lot of
different topics around business yeah
here you see the different categories
the different media formats yeah and
here you see the different blogs that
they're topic writing about yes so
generative AI can help you tailor
messaging here is the article yeah and
here you see also the call to action
that we talked about subscribe to
Harvard Business Review yeah they have
here options to monetize the uh the blog
and here you talk about subscribe yeah
subscribe all simple call to actions
here is a summary of the article is the
article itself we talked about that
here's the social sharing button yeah
here's the visual that they use so all
the aspects that we talked about earlier
are available in this blog
yeah but these are typical thought
leadership blogs that can really help in
developing yourself as an expert
case study blogs they are sort of
blocked with articles that give an
in-depth analysis of a single topic
yeah so typically to prove a point or
back up an argument yeah so this is kind
of background information to make your
point so good example for that is
HubSpot
yeah so HubSpot is a marketing
automation system they have one of the
best blogs in the industry yeah where
they give lots of background information
on all the different social media
digital marketing topics that you can
find yeah so here you see how a home
page of a Blog can be organized that is
your featured post here you have more
featured posts you see it's very visual
here you have the last sort of blog
posts here you see last categories and
the blog post call to action call to
action here yeah another category and
then to make it more exciting we'll add
videos to this page as well
yeah so good example of a case study
blog yeah and and a general blog in with
all the features that it needs you then
have video and audio blocks video
becomes more and more important as a
Channel of communication yes so
start using video we also have seen the
growth of podcasting start using audio
Yeah and use those as part of your
blogging strategy as well here's a good
example yeah that is SoundCloud now
SoundCloud is a website which is kind of
the YouTube for audio Yeah for for uh
for podcasts for audio files and here
you see their blog which a good mix of
news resources audio files blog posts
with text yeah and video files as well
so it's a perfect combination of all the
elements that we're talking about here
yeah so very important to use video and
audio blogs as well here are some more
types of blogs news jacking or news
posts they provide information on recent
events or developments in a specific
industry yeah so good news checking a
hacking website is wired yes
specifically focus on technology
yeah and it is a go-to place for the
latest news on technology
it's you see a very clear style you see
it on the visuals as well yeah and it's
again it is a new kind of portal yeah
which gives you access to all the blog
posts it doesn't really look like a Blog
it looks like a news portal and that is
particularly for news websites a very
common way of using a blogging platform
to create a news portal okay we're then
looking at infographics posts now you
may have heard of infographics they uh
um are Graphics that simplify complex
materials with a chart graphs and
Graphics yep and then you can do blog
posts around those as well you have one
of my favorites and you should follow
them on Facebook for and on LinkedIn the
visual capitalist the visual capitalist
has a everyday they come out with a new
chart yeah or a new infographic on a
particular topic yeah so here you see an
infographic on the top 50 most visited
websites in the world
so here's the infographic and then here
is to text sort of the background
information about it yeah so here's the
visuals so you see Google yeah you see
YouTube Facebook Twitter so here you see
how that all sort of um how that
develops yes so with the text subscribe
to it
yeah so good visual comparison
so very powerful website so use those
type of websites use that type of way of
presenting your your information we then
look at how two posts they offer a
detailed instruction on how to do a
particular task yeah people love those
a good example of how to block is set
godin's block
yep where he has very simple design for
his blog but this is all about the
content so he has a story of the week or
his top 100 posts yeah so how to tell a
great story advice for outer how to be
remarket how to write an ebook how to do
permission marketing an email checklist
very down to earth simple how-to tips
when it comes to business very
straightforward very popular blog when
it comes to how to posts and then last
but not least a very powerful type of
blog is the guest Post Yeah so why would
you write on your own blog why can't you
be a guest blogger on somebody else's
post has lots of benefits from a search
engine perspective as well for the
author of The Blog because you have
other websites that recognize your your
expertise in your area they invite you
to write about that and Google sees that
as a high Authority ranking signal for
your search yeah good example of a
um a guest post is Neil Patel who has
its own website has his own blog is
really well recognized as a digital
marketing expert yep and here he is
writing an article as a guest on the
HubSpot blog yep so very useful very
powerful way and very powerful type of
blog post that you can that you can
write
okay so those are the different blog
posts so let's look at how you go about
creating a Blog there's a number of
steps that you need to look at first of
all you need to look at what is the CMS
or the blogging platform that you're
going to use
yeah it's a very important decision for
bloggers because there's seven several
sort of decisions that you need to make
here first of all you're going to look
at am I going to use a simple platform
which is often free to begin with or am
I going professional straight away so if
you're going simple yep then you can go
for tools like wordpress.com
or wix.com they will host the website
for you and those are the typical tools
that give you some basic functionality
in the free version you will have your
website up and running within five
minutes but then if you want more
functionality you pay a bit more
yep now or you want to decide to go
professional which means you're going to
go to a web hosting provider and you're
going to install your own website on
their servers yep and one of the most
popular platforms for that is
wordpress.org which is a different
version of Wordpress
wordpress.org gives you a lot more
flexibility a lot more freedom a lot
more
plugins yeah but it is a bit more
complicated to set up
yep and there is some the WordPress
itself doesn't cost you any money but
the hosting will cost you money yeah the
questions that you need to ask yourself
whether you want to go simple or complex
are hey
um what do you want your blog to do do
you just want to get it for your sharing
your expertise or do you want to
monetize your blog yeah do you want to
run it as the website for your business
for instance what are your technical
skills do you have very limited
technical skills you may want to go for
a hosted version on wordpress.com or Wix
or Weeble yeah do you have sufficient
technical skills you may want to go for
the wordpress.org version which is the
hosted version you need to think about
your budget yeah do you have budget to
use a hosted platform yep and of course
you need to look at the features of the
platforms that you use can you find
yourself in the features that you want
to use for that yeah so that is the
first question that you want to ask
yourself where are you going to host
your website and that is what blogging
platform are you going to use step two
is you're going to look at your domain
name of course very important that is
the name of your website the name of
your blog it's a unique web address that
is identified that identifies your blog
on the internet
yes so when you choose your domain name
make sure make sure it is memorable it
is reflective of your brand people
recognize it it's available on other
social media websites as well yep so it
hasn't been taken by other people on
Facebook or Instagram yeah and maybe use
your keywords that are relevant for your
blog so lots of things that you need to
do if you want to have a domain then you
can check on
um on sites like GoDaddy if the domain
name is available yeah then when you
have it you can then buy it and you
usually pay the register for a year over
two years if it's a very simple name
that hasn't uh that's that is not very
popular then it often costs you maybe
ten dollars if it is a more popular name
that hasn't been registered yet you may
pay more
okay so then you also need to think
about the extension of your domain is it
going to be a.com is it going to be a
DOT net is it going to be a DOT org or
is it going to be a country extension
like dot NL for the Netherlands yes so
um or dot FR for France
common rule is if you're targeting a
local market take the URL of the local
market if you're targeting a global
market go for the.com or the dot net but
preferably the.com if you're an organ a
government organization then you want to
usually stick to the dot org
then of course you will have checked the
availability of your domain and then
you're going to register the domain
yes so you provide your contact
information you pay a small or a large
fee depending on the popularity of the
name and then in your website your blog
setup you're going to connect the domain
to your blog so that means updating the
name servers in your domain's registry
account so it then points to your blog
Hosting account
yeah so a very simple uh or good
provider you can go to is GoDaddy
dot.com or dot Co dot UK and they give
you everything yeah so type the domain
that you want yeah they can help you
create your website they have different
types of services they do domain names
they do website and hosting and they do
email marketing they have really good
support
yeah so if you want to type your domain
so let's take a for instance
um do uh company ABC is going to be my
domain
yep and you see here company abc dot Co
dot UK is available
yes so
um there is here's the company letter
you see if you want to use that one it's
a premium name so here you see all the
different varieties on the name
yeah here basiccompany.com that would
cost you three thousand pounds because
it is a quite a popular name
yeah so it is available but
yeah value for money
okay so that is your
um choosing your domain name then you're
going to look at your hosting plan and
your hosting plan is very important you
will only select the hosting plan if you
go for a hosted
blog solution yeah so which you do with
wordpress.org for instance so basically
when you select your hosting plan you
buy a bit of storage space on the
servers of that hosting profiler and on
that spit of storage space you install
your website and then the service the
hosting provider will connect that to
the Internet so they provide technology
and the support to store and maintain
your website
yes so that is a very important part and
again you need to consider your budget
and you also need to consider your
website requirements you need to look at
the reliability and the speed and the
uptime yeah so a reliable hosting
provider they offer you high uptime
percentage and fast loading times that
is very important
yep and you need to very carefully look
at customer support yeah so make sure
they offer 24 7 support preferably with
a chat option because often you have to
wait a long time to get access and if
you have a chat option it's much easier
to get your
um to get your problems solved and a
very important part of your hosting plan
as well is your security yeah make sure
that there is a spam protection on your
website and also look at your https yeah
so get your SSL certificate for your for
your website
yes so now some popular hosting
providers you can look at include
GoDaddy Bluehost HostGator dreamhost
take the time to research them yeah and
evaluate each option and certainly look
at the customer reviews as well
next step is you're going to design your
blog yeah so once you've created or you
selected your hosting provider you're
then going to set up your blog and you
would install
wordpress.org yeah and then you're going
to create your website now the first
thing that most of those CMS yet
platforms will ask you is what theme do
you want to pick
and they have a whole library of themes
that you can pick and choose from
and there's lots of websites that allow
you to buy themes whether it's a
photography theme a health theme a a
business theme and then you can just buy
that theme install it in your WordPress
setup yep and then you download the demo
for it and then you have your website
the only thing you have to do is change
the content and the visuals and your
website is ready yes so very important
that you pick a very powerful sort of
theme you then can customize the theme
with your own photos your own logo your
own color schemes your own options so
you can make it a unique look and feel
you then add your own images yeah you
customize the header of the website
so and then you can use custom widgets
small medium modules that you can add to
your website that do things like sign up
for my newsletter or uh
what's it click on the RSS feed of your
website Etc and then often you can add
your own sort of HTML coding or css
coding as well to give your website
additional functionality a really good
place to buy themes are is themes
forests dot net
yeah so there's a whole range of themes
you can say for instance give me an
entertainment themes here you see
entertainment themes could be
um yeah so you want WordPress
yeah for instance WordPress themes and
then you just pick a theme yeah you can
actually do a live preview of the theme
yeah and this is here see the demos
we want the uh no coding so take for
instance this one here taste the
difference and there you see immediately
how your website will look like
how your blog will look like
yeah so then you download the theme
install it on WordPress
download the demo and again then the
only thing you have to do is change the
text and the visuals yeah and some
design elements
so it's so easy there's not a single
line of programming that you have to do
these days yeah when it comes to your
web development and that is a big
concern that people had do I still have
to program no you don't it's all sort of
intuitive step five start creating your
content
of course when your blog is live when
your blog is up and running you need to
start creating content for your blog too
by writing posts adding images creating
Pages organizing your content using the
categories and the tags making it easier
for people to find now before you can
start writing your posts you of course
you need to know what you're going to
write about yeah what is your focus what
is your Niche what are your interests
what is your passion you need to do
keyword research around those topics
yeah so that gives you the ability to
understand what your target audience
want to read about yet use tools like
Google Keyword Planner and we've done an
earlier video on how to use Google
Keyword Planner to find relevant
keywords for your blog
create an editorial calendar very
important know that every week you're
going to do a blog post yeah so every
Monday you need to draft a post
Wednesday you want to publish it yeah so
look forward maybe write four or eight
blog posts in advance and then you are
ready for the next eight weeks then
start writing your first blog post yeah
that introduces the blog and introduces
your Niche create a Content strategy
have a visual strategy and optimize your
blog posts for search using the keywords
yeah and using the meta tags for your
blogs
so that is really important because
Google loves to show blog posts higher
up in the um in the search results now
remember it takes time quality content
takes time and effort so take the time
to research search your topics and make
sure that you write compelling and
informative blog posts and promote your
content on social media and other
channels so that drives traffic back to
your website
and then finally we're going to look at
how to share your blog very important
you need to promote your blog and you
need to track your performance yeah so
share your blog on social media
platforms
engage with your audience when they have
comments or when they give feedback use
email marketing to promote your blog
yeah collaborate with other bloggers or
websites in your Niche try to get those
blogging those guest blogging
opportunities and use paid advertising
to promote your blog
yes so it's an ongoing effort and it
requires consistent effort
yeah on the tracking side use Google
analytics so set up your blog with
Google analytics so you get information
about traffic about your audience and um
about your most popular pages and your
most popular blog posts yes so you can
track specific actions in Google
analytics so how many people are at a
signing up for the newsletter for
instance monitor your social media
analytics how popular are your blog
posts uh the Facebook post about your
blog on Twitter or on Facebook or on
Instagram yeah look at open rates
click-through rates and regularly review
your blog's performance and adjust your
strategy if necessary
yes so very important part don't keep
your blog a secret start promoting it
high and wide
okay so let's close the session with
some writing tips
first of all know your audience
understand who is your target audience
and what are they looking for in your
blog yeah we talked about customer
personas create customer personas for
your key audiences yep and you're
writing for them you're not writing for
yourself you need to hit the language
that resonates with your audience
be authentic write in your own voice let
your personality shine through don't
write Anonymous yeah people want to see
the writer the author behind the or the
um the uh the article
yeah make sure that you research your
topic because that will help you in
writing authoritatively and then when
you write authoritatively you provide
value to your readers
don't limit yourself to text use images
use videos to supplement your writing
make your blog visually appealing
it goes without saying edit proofread
prove read proofread there's nothing
more frustrating than typos in your blog
posts yeah make sure your writing is
clear it is simple it is polished and
there's no typos in there just copy your
blog text put it in a word processor yep
and then do a spelling checker then
finally be consistent consistency is key
to building your audience and for your
readers to come back
yes so and be consistent in the timing
as well try to do it daily or weekly or
monthly but give that consistency to
your readers
and if you take all these things
together and you are passionate about a
topic then I'm sure you're going to be
successful with your blog so good luck
with this yeah this is a wrap this is it
it's a short introduction to blogging
Basics as it were yeah how can you start
your blog so take these these tips and
don't be scared start a blog do it
straight away because it is actually
really fun to do so if you want to know
more about all this check out the other
simply learned courses if you like this
video click the like and if you want to
subscribe click the Subscribe button
below yep so and that gives you access
to our channel of of other
Learners
so that's it for now and I will see you
all at the next video
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here